eric laval donc ça fait quelques jours
qu'on est là depuis le début de la
semaine donc fut mieux revoir mais mes
partenaires que j'ai l'habitude de
travailler ensemble c'est tout de
l'année et ce soir je présentais
affleurer mon registre des épices donc
en avant première du salon de
l'agriculture voilà donc fait content
d'être là
pendant ces dix jours sur le site du
salon de l'agriculture donc moi c'est
les produits c'est les épices donc ma
ramène de la flotte celle évidemment
baies roses du gala b du sirop de gala b
sirop de gingembre
vinaigre ananas victoria
[Musique]
vinaigre carré vaut mon point tu
lui le combat avant
lui le combat va café bon au point tu me
ramener le gall a b g n va ni évidemment
la vanille temps est à l'honneur on
essaie la vanille bio donc on a ramené
salle ramet du sucre évidemment
venir ici ce en étant que pie xi et par
année du sucre mélasse non non
c'est la quatrième fois que je
participerai au salon de l'agriculture
toujours superbe ces sites d'être à
paris et présenté vendredi à paris c'est
ce que l'on attend le haut vont mieux à
paris on représente la gastronomie
française et représenter sa région ile
de la réunion ici c'est c'est
extraordinaire